In the midst of all the turmoil in the
Middle East, a prominent Egyptian sheh
is calling on Donald Trump to follow
guidance.
Yes, in a video, Sheikh Mustafa Alawi
made the following summons.
Quote, a message to Trump, the great one
of America. Peace to whoever follows
guidance.
Submit and all will go well for you.
Submit and God will reward you twice. If
you wield authority, you will be held
accountable. Know, Mr. President, that
you will die and be resurrected alone.
You will be held accountable and
punished.
[Applause]
He repeats, you will be held accountable
and punished. So do righteous deeds. God
granted you kingship, and he alone can
withdraw it. Do not be deceived by being
a king or president. Those before you
have died. Where is Johnson? Where is
Nixon? Where is Kennedy? They all passed
away and were buried under the earth. Do
not be deluded by military funerals or
wreaths of flowers on graves. Know that
your deeds will be exposed one day. You
are in the path of arrogance. And the
Lord of glory said, "He created you from
weakness, then made after weakness
strength, then after strength, weakness,
and white hair. So submit and all will
go well for you. God will reward you
twice." On the surface, these seem like
philosophical observations worthy of a
Marcus Aurelius. The sheh simply appears
to be warning an aging Trump to repent.
Stop doing evil in the Middle East.
Follow proper guidance and therefore
find peace before meeting your maker. In
reality, the entire message is infused
with threats of jihad, specifically
threats for Donald Trump to embrace
Islam or else. And I know this because
the formulaic words the sheh used, which
I first dissected in a 20-year-old
article when Osama bin Laden was in the
habit of uttering those words, have a
long and storied history. First, a
little background. Soon after the
September 11, 2011 attacks, al-Qaeda
leader Osama bin Laden began sending
messages and communicates to the West,
many of which I translated and annotated
in the Al-Qaeda Reader published in
2007. Just as Shikh Aladdawi is doing
now, so too did bin Laden begin and end
his messages with the phrase peace to
whoever follows guidance. What were
Americans and Europeans to understand by
this simple statement? Considering that
it was always anchored in messages rife
with grievances and accusations which
culminated with threats of reciprocal
treatment, those addressed assumed that
bin Laden's guidance was for the West to
terminate hostilities against the
Islamic world and thereby earn peace for
itself. Hence why the al-Qaeda leader
would say things such as an eye for an
eye, a tooth for a tooth. Or quote, "The
time to settle accounts has arrived.
Just as you kill, so shall you be
killed. Just as you bomb, so too shall
you be bombed. In context, then the
overall impression that bin Laden gave
and that Shik alawi is now giving is
that whoever follows guidance, i.e.
whoever follows the wise advice being
offered will have peace. Live and let
live. In reality, a long and bellose
history revolves around this seemingly
peaceful proverb, peace to whoever
follows guidance. A history which those
being addressed are totally oblivious
of. This phrase was in fact first
uttered by the prophet of Islam,
Muhammad, and had nothing to do with
payback or a desire to live and let
live. After Muhammad had converted most
of Arabia to Islam by the power of the
sword, he set his sight on his
neighbors, including the Christians to
the north and west, known in the Arabic
sources as the Romans. In this context
of wars and rumors of wars, Muhammad
sent the following tur message to the
Eastern Roman Emperor Heraclus in 622
AD. It reads, quote, "In the name of
God, the compassionate, the merciful,
from Muhammad, the messenger of God, to
Heracleus, the Roman emperor, peace to
whoever follows guidance, submit and all
will go well for you."
The translation submit and all will go
well for you, is based on a two-word
Arabic pun, Islam, which most literally
means submit and have peace or submit
and be whole. After Heraculus refused to
submit, that is convert to Islam, jihad
was declared against Christendom as
enshrined in Quran 9:29. And in a few
decades, nearly twothirds of the then
Christian world, including Spain, all of
North Africa, Egypt, and greater Syria
were conquered. Such are the fruits of
this seemingly innocuous phrase, Islam,
which Aladi is now directing at Trump.
From Islam's perspective, the latest
Heracleus or Roman emperor.
Incidentally, keep in mind that it's a
fundamental tenet of Islam for jihad to
persevere until the entire globe is
either converted to or at least governed
by Islam. When the abode of war, i.e.
the non-Islamic world or in Arabic dalb
has been subsumed into the abode of
Islam that is alm then and only then can
there be peace. From here we have a
better understanding of the etmological
relationship between the words Islam and
peace. a relationship often distorted
through conflation. Even though Islam or
Islam and the Arabic word for peace are
formed from the same three-lettered root
sal and thus are in fact related, only
the word salam means peace. Islam or
Islam means submit or surrender. The
connection between the two words then is
clear. In Islam, peace is the goal, but
only through submission, just as
Muhammad plainly proclaimed to Heraclus,
and just as Egyptian Shikh Aladawi is
proclaiming to the American president.
Now, there are three other points to
bear in mind whenever Muslims come
around offering peace to whoever follows
guidance. First, powerful illusions in
imagery and thus context are
established, earning those Muslims more
legitimacy within the Islamic world. For
now they are seen as walking in the
footsteps of Muhammad using his exact
terminology and addressing it to the
spiritual descendants of Heracleus in
Christian Rome that is the west as the
age-old struggle between Islam and
infidelity the abode of Islam and the
abode of war rages on. Second as with
all of Muhammad's habits his approach to
infidels first demanding that they
submit then attacking them if they
refuse has become standardized. In other
words, before attacking infidels,
Muslims like their prophet should first
call on them to submit to Islam by
evoking the opening sentence of
Muhammad's archetypal message. They
legitimize the subsequent terror they
plan on visiting upon the infidels.
Third, and most importantly, Muslims who
use Muhammad's phraseology accomplish
all of the above while simultaneously
fooling the people of the West, who
according to their own epistemology
assume that the guidance through which
Muslims are offering peace, is simply a
poetic way of saying, "Leave us alone
and we'll leave you alone." Yet, the
allimportant historical and religious
connotations, much acknowledged and
appreciated in the Islamic world, are
altogether missed in the West.
The good news is that two decades after
I first exposed this Islam business,
many are no longer fooled. For example,
several outlets that translated Aladi's
words literally translated his Islam
submit have peace as quote convert to
Islam. While that's not exactly what he
said, and thus Muslims can argue that
those crazy Islamophobes are
mistransating his words, it is as seen
what he meant. Anyway, now you know the
particulars behind Islam's ancient
summons. More importantly, now you know
that the nonsensical claim that Islam
means peace, as President George W. Bush
literally claimed days after 9/11, is
pure hogwash. It means submit to Islam
and then have peace. Bye.